bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur arte france alors depuis la fia
skripal les relations sont très tendues
entre les deux puissances londres 1 qui
accuse moscou d'être derrière une
campagne de piratage pourquoi ces
allégations répétées la grande-bretagne
1 semble avoir besoin à la fois de
prouver son indépendance avec décision
d'ubs rexie tu mets tout en continuant à
faire allégeance au mans globaliste
atlantiste donc elle avait déjà pris des
sanctions
là elle continue en fait sur la ligne d
accusation au pourrait il semblerait
nous pensons il est possible que sans
jamais en fait de produire aucune preuve
réelle donc nous sommes toujours dans le
cas d'un tribunal médiatico politique
contre la russie qui sert à continuer à
construire la figure de l'ennemi
en ce qui concerne concrètement les en
plus il est à l'effet reprocher c'est
assez amusant parce que par exemple pour
le virus on appréciera le tamis puisque
la russie qui travaille aussi de son
côté sur les sur les vaccins mais
aujourd'hui a annoncé que des personnes
les premières personnes qui l'ont testé
sont sortis et que ce vaccin sur eux
fonctionnent en tout cas donc quel est
l'intérêt d'aller chercher les vaccins
des autres par ailleurs on se souviendra
que lorsqu'il y avait réellement un
risque pour l'humanité la guerre froide
n'assumant pas du tout empêché l'urss et
les états unis de lutter ensemble contre
la variole
donc si le vide est à ce point dangereux
qu'il faille d'urgence tout de suite
cherché un vaccin
pourquoi dans ce cas là les pays ne
travaillent pas ensemble pourquoi chacun
ne propose pas ces avancées aux autres
si ce n'est pas beaucoup plus logique
ou alors ça nous obligerait à penser que
d'une certaine manière l'ampleur de ce
virus est plus politique que need l'art
à chaque fois ces accusations n'ont pas
de
preuves fondées pourquoi aujourd'hui
c'est devenu récurrent tous les regards
se retourne se tourne pardon vers la
russie lorsqu'il est question de
piratage informatique on parle aussi
l'ingérence dans des élections que sur
les élections américaines ou
britanniques là en l'occurrence on parle
jamais justement du rôle des états unis
ou de la chine
et pourquoi les ingérences justement à
numérique vous le dites l'intérêt du
monde numérique c'est un monde virtuel
dans le sens direct du terme
ce n'est pas un monde réel donc c'est
quasiment impossible d'apporter les
preuves réelles de ce qu'on avance
ce qui donne finalement carte blanche
pour toutes les accusations possibles
le rôle de la russie et celui en quelque
sorte du méchant qui va permettre de
consolider les chantiers entre eux qui
ont entre eux un certain nombre de
divergences donc a accusé la russie
c'est très pratique pour maintenir une
certaine solidarité factice entre les
différents états qui font partie du bloc
atlantiste à différents niveaux l'on
voit par exemple derrière les
accusations lancées par la grande
bretagne tout de suite
un membre du congrès américain kevin
mccarthy un nom pareil pour cent ce
cas-là ça s'invente pas annoncé qu' un
projet de loi pour prendre des formes
étranges de la responsabilité pénale de
ces hackers russes va être annoncée va
être discutée au congrès pourquoi
uniquement les hackers russes
il existe effectivement comme vous
voulez d'autres hackers en chine etc
mais géopolitiquement le combat entre
les etats-unis et la chine n'est pas un
combat politique c'est un combat que
mercy est un combat économique avec la
russie le combat et politiques si la
question de l'existence du monde global
atlantique parce que mon global de
peut-être que atlantique qui peut y
avoir qu'un centre politique et la
russie est dangereuse en contestant
l'existence de cette unité du centre
politique on peut dire que c'est une
nouvelle guerre froide virtuel
c'est une nouvelle guerre froide virtuel
à se demander en fait si la guerre
froide a réellement pris fin dans les
années 90 la russie était trop faible
pour avoir une position politique
vous payez en quelque sorte la guerre
froide a été suspendue une certaine
manière il est tout à fait normal que
des pays des puissances politiques
soient concurrence entre elles la
politique c'est un jeu de concurrence
donc en quelque sorte c'est un très bon
signe pour la russie lorsque le clan
opposé la combat ce qui est beaucoup
plus dangereux c'est lorsque l'on a vu
comme dans les années 90 et l'union
européenne et les etats unis extrêmement
aimable avec le clan yvelines
ce n'était pas forcément pour le mieux
dans le sang merci beaucoup cars nv
chagalov quoi d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou